Me perguntaram outro dia, doutor, qual
que é a sua abordagem para tratamento de
câncer de mama em conjunto com
tratamento ortodoxo ou convencional?
Bem, hoje nós vamos conversar sobre um
tema que toca a vida de muitas famílias
brasileiras e que merece nossa atenção
especial, que é abordagem integrativa no
tratamento do câncer de mama. Sabe
quando você vai numa consulta e o médico
só olha pro exame, pro tumor, pra
doença, mas esquece que ali tem uma
pessoa inteira com emoções, com uma
vida, com sonhos? Pois é. A medicina
integrativa vem justamente para mudar
esse jogo. Imaginem só, uma paciente
chega no meu consultório assustada com
diagnóstico e eu falo para ela: "Olha,
vamos sim fazer todo o tratamento
convencional ortodoxo que a oncologia
oferece, mas vamos turbinar o seu corpo
para ele ser seu maior aliado nessa
batalha". Então o que eu vou fazer aqui
nesse vídeo é tentar em um curto espaço
de tempo passar para vocês rapidamente
sobre alguns elementos importantes no
tratamento integrativo do câncer de
mama. Não vai ser um vídeo para falar de
todos os suplementos, é uma tarefa
complexa e desafiadora, porque é muita
coisa, mas eu vou tentar pincelar um
pouco sobre cada assunto e agradecendo o
Dr. José de Felipe Júnior, que anos
atrás me ensinou boa parte desse
protocolo e por isso sou muito grato.
Então vamos começar pela vitamina D de
dado, gente. Nossa, que coisa
impressionante. Tivemos um estudo
recente da Unesp de Botucatu mostrando
que pacientes que tomaram vitamina D
junto com a quimioterapia tiveram 43% de
resposta patológica completa. 43%.
Então, enquanto quem não tomou ficou em
24%. Então, é o quase o dobro de
eficácia. E olha que interessante, não
precisa de megadoses não, viu? O estudo
usou somente 2.000 unidades por dia, uma
dose bem tranquila. Mas esa aí, não é só
tomar a vitamina e pronto, tem que tomar
sol também. Eu sempre falo pros meus
pacientes, 15 a 30 minutinhos, três
vezes por semana, entre 11 e 14 horas.
Eu sei, eu sei. Todo mundo fala para
fugir do sol nesse horário, mas é
justamente quando ele tá mais forte para
produzir vitamina D na nossa pele. E tem
um truque, depois de pegar sol, fica uma
horinha sem tomar banho. Por quê? Porque
a vitamina D se forma na superfície da
pele e precisa de um tempinho para ser
absorvida. Se você corre pro chuveiro,
tchau a vitamina. Agora vem uma parte
que o pessoal sempre acha diferente, a
água hidrogenada. Parece coisa de filme
de ficção científica, né? Mas não é não.
A água com hidrogênio molecular tem um
potencial antioxidante brutal. Então,
estamos falando aqui de umpencial
de óxido redução de -450 mV ou mais
negativo ainda. Isso significa que essa
água é uma verdadeira esponja de
radicais livres. E olha que bacana, dá
para fazer em casa com hidrogenador
portátil que você compra na internet. E
tem mais, a gente prepara essa água com
uma mistura especial de nutrientes, de
minerais, para tornar essa água
estruturada. Tem magnésio em várias
formas, tem o potássio, o cálcio, é como
se fosse um soro caseiro turbinado. 1 L,
1,5 L por dia dessa água e o corpo
agradece. As células cancerígenas odeiam
o ambiente alcalino e bem oxigenado.
Então, estamos criando um ambiente
hostil para elas. Vamos falar de sono
agora. Melatonina, minha gente, 20 mg
sublingual ao deitar. Parece muito. Pois
é. A dose usual para dormir é bem menor,
mas aqui estamos usando a melatonina
como agente antitumoral. Tem estudo
brasileiro mostrando que ela regula
genes específicos em tumores de mama. A
melatonina não é só o hormônio do sono,
ela também é uma guerreira contra o
câncer. E sabe o que mais? Ela reduz os
efeitos colaterais da químio e da
radioterapia. E a curcumina, o princípio
ativo do açafrão. Que maravilha da
natureza. Olha só que interessante. Ela
consegue atuar em múltiplos alvos ao
mesmo tempo. Enquanto os remédios
modernos miram num alvo só. A curcumina
é tipo um canivete suíço. Faz várias
coisas ao mesmo tempo. Inibe a formação
de vasos sanguíneos que alimentam tumor,
induz a morte de células cancerígenas,
apoptose, reduz inflamação e é muita
coisa. Mas tem um porém. A cucumina
sozinha é mal absorvida. Então, no
protocolo, ela vem junto com a piperina,
que é da pimenta preta. A piperina
aumenta absorção da cucumina em 2000%. É
como se você tomasse uma colher de
açafrão com pimenta e seu corpo
aproveitasse como se fossem 20 colheres.
E não para por aí, tem o jean, o jean
dolmetano, que vem dos vegetais
crucíferos, tipo brócolis e covlor. Esse
composto é fantástico para modular os
hormônios e especialmente importante no
câncer de mama, que muitas vezes é
hormônio dependente. Tem também a
trexona de baixa dose, que modula o
sistema imune. Tem o BCG sonicado, que é
como uma vacina que acorda o nosso
sistema de defesa. A alimentação também
muda completamente. É importante você
temporariamente cortar a carne vermelha,
o frango e o porco. Pode de peixe, pó de
ovos. E olha que interessante, um bife
de fígado por semana. Por quê? Porque o
fígado é riquíssimo em vitaminas do
complexo B, ferro e outros nutrientes
essenciais pro sistema imune. Leite
derivados proteicos, nem pensar, mas
manteiga e creme de leite podem. É
estranho, não é? É porque a proteína do
leite pode estimular fatores de
crescimento que a gente não quer nesse
momento. Lembrando que eu não acho que a
carne vermelha e de frango sejam ruins,
mas no protocolo do câncer a gente tem
razões para acreditar que ela pode
atrapalhar pelo menos em um determinado
momento. Olha que curioso, o protocolo
manda forrar com manta térmica de
alumínio embaixo do colchão do sofá e da
cadeira do escritório. E parece maluquí,
mas não é. Existem zonas geopatogênicas
radiações naturais da Terra que podem
interferir no nosso campo
eletromagnético. Então, a manta de
alumínio bloqueia as radiações. É o
mesmo princípio dos cobertores térmicos
de emergência. E aidade física é
fundamental, mas não precisa virar
atleta, não. Caminhada de passo firme,
30 minutos, três a quatro vezes por
semana. Natação excelente.
Hidroginástica com carga. O exercício
melhora a oxigenação, fortalece o
sistema imune, reduz inflamação, melhor
humor e é um remédio sem
contraindicação. Tem também um sal
especial que é o sal de Carpanen. É um
sal com menos sódio, mais potássio e
magnésio. Isso ajuda a polarizar a
membrana celular e célula bem polarizada
funciona direito e célula despolarizada
vira bagunça. Ainda tem a lisina e iodo
nesse sal que são importantes pro
sistema imune. E os fitoterápicos entram
pesados, seja extrato de alecrim,
manjericão, sálvia. Não é tempero de
comida, não são doses terapêuticas.
Extrato de ne, que é uma árvore indiana
com propriedades antimicrobianas e
antitumorais incríveis. Tem o extrato de
folha de oliveira, rico e oleopeína,
extrato de cardo mareno pro fígado, que
precisa estar tinindo para metabolizar
tudo isso. A artemisina também merece um
capítulo à parte. Ela é derivada de uma
planta chinesa, artemísia anua e
funciona assim. As células cancerígenas
acumulam muito ferro e a termisina reage
com esse ferro e forma radicais livres
que matam especificamente as células
doentes. É como uma bomba inteligente.
Por isso o protocolo manda tomar 7 dias
sim, 7 dias não, para não criar
resistência. O ácido alfalipoico a com
enzima Q10 são antioxidantes poderosos
que protegem as células saudáveis
enquanto o tratamento ataca as doentes.
É como usar um colete à prova de balas
enquanto você enfrenta o inimigo. O
seleno na forma de selenometonina, 200
micr por dia, é fundamental pro sistema
imune e tem ação antitumoral comprovada.
E não podemos esquecer das frutas e
vegetais específicos. Frutas vermelhas e
roxas, amora, cereja, framboesa,
morango, uva roxa, açaí, são ricas e
antocianinas, pigmentos com ação
antioxidante potente. O protocolo limita
a frutose a 25 g por dia, então não é
para comer 1 kg de fruta, não. É para
escolher bem e comer com moderação. Os
vegetais exclusivos são obrigatórios,
seja brócolis, couve e flor, couve de
bruxelas, repolho. Eles têm compostos
sulfurados que ajudam o fígado a
eliminar toxinas e hormônios em excesso.
Então o sulforafano do brócolis é um dos
compostos anticâncer mais potentes que
existe na natureza. Tem também o
protocolo relativamente recente e muito
polêmico, Dr. William Max, que utiliza
aí substâncias reposicionadas que eram
consideradas somente antiparasitárias.
Mas eu não vou entrar em detalhes sobre
isso nesse vídeo para não sofrer nenhum
tipo de retaliação, punição da
plataforma. Mas cabe dizer que é uma
combinação da IvET com outro medicamento
em altas doses. Agora, deixa eu contar
uma coisa importante. Isso tudo não
substitui o tratamento convencional, não
mesmo. É para fazer tudo junto, entende?
É a união da medicina moderna com a
sabedoria da natureza. Quando o
cologista fala para fazer químio faz a
químia. Quando indica cirurgia, opera.
mais tubinado com tudo isso que eu falei
aqui. E tem que ter acompanhamento
personalizado, gente. Não é pegar essa
lista e sair tomando tudo por conta.
Precisa ajustar as doses, ver
interações, acompanhar exames. Cada
pessoa é única, cada caso é um caso que
funciona para uma pessoa pode não
funcionar para outra. Por isso a
importância de um profissional
especializado em medicina funcional para
acompanhar o seu caso e que sabe o que
você está fazendo. Olha, eu sei que é
muita coisa, falei coisa demais aqui, é
avaçalador, é até overwhelming, como
dizem os americanos, mas pensa assim,
você não precisa fazer tudo de uma vez,
vai implementando aos poucos, começa com
o sol e a vitamina D, depois inclui a
melatonina, vai mudando a alimentação
devagar, é um processo e não uma
corrida. e procure um bom médico da
medicina funcional, que tem essa
filosofia de medicina funcional
integrativa para fazer o seu
acompanhamento. E o mais bonito disso
tudo é ver que a transformação das
pacientes é muito maravilhosa. Chegam
assustadas, sem esperança e aos poucos
vão percebendo que tem ferramentas para
lutar, que o corpo delas não é um
traidor, mas um aliado que só precisa de
armas certas. Eu vi pacientes que não só
venceram o câncer, mas saíram mais
fortes, mais conscientes, mais saudáveis
do que eram antes do diagnóstico. Porque
no fundo, no fundo, o que estamos
fazendo é desenvolver
o corpo na sua capacidade de defender e
curar. O sistema imune humano é uma
máquina perfeita quando funciona
direito. O câncer só aparece quando algo
fala nesse sistema. Então, em vez de só
atacar o tumor, vamos consertar o
sistema todo. E sabe o que mais me
emociona? É que boa parte disso não é
caro ou inacessível. Só é de graça.
Vitamina D custa pouquíssimo. Açafrô
você compra na feira, brócolis e couve,
tá tudo ali no supermercado. Caminhar
não custa nada, é medicina do povo,
acessível e democrática.
Claro que tem vários suplementos aí que
são bem mais caros, mas dá para adaptar.
O importante é o conceito, nutrir o
corpo, alcalinizar o ambiente interno,
oxigenar as células, modular o sistema
imune, reduzir inflamação, melhorar o
sono e controlar o estresse. Isso é o
fundamental. E não esqueçam, o emocional
conta muito, muito mesmo. O medo, a
raiva, a tristeza, tudo isso deprime o
sistema imune. Por isso é importante, é
fundamental manter a mente e o espírito
equilibrados para poder modular
neurotransmissores que são importantes
pro sistema imune. Pessoal, o que eu
quero que vocês levem daqui hoje é
esperança. Esperança baseada em ciência,
em estudos, em resultados reais. O
câncer não é uma sentença de morte, é um
desafio, sim, mas um desafio que pode
ser vencido. E quanto mais ferramentas
tivermos, maiores as chances de vitória.
Então não é questão de você eliminar
tratamentos, mas de combinar os
tratamentos. Lembre-se, o corpo humano é
sábio, ele quer viver, ele quer estar
saudável, às vezes só precisa de uma
ajudinha para lembrar como fazer isso. E
é isso que a medicina funcional oferece,
essa ajudinha, esse empurrãozinho na
direção certa. Se você conhece alguém
passando por isso, compartilha essa
informação. Conhecimento é poder e pode
salvar a sua vida. E poder sobre a sua
própria saúde é libertador. Vamos juntos
mudar a forma como enfrentamos o câncer,
consciência, com natureza, com esperança
e principalmente com muito amor e
cuidado pelo ser humano integral que
existe por trás de cada diagnóstico. E a
medicina do futuro é essa, integrativa,
personalizada, preventiva e
participativa. E o futuro, meus amigos,
ele já chegou, está aqui agora ao
alcance de todos nós. Basta coragem de
abraçar o novo sem abandonar o que já
funciona. é somar, não dividir, é
integrar, como o próprio nome diz. Um
grande abraço a todos. Cuidem-se e
lembrem-se, a saúde é o nosso bem mais
precioso. Vamos lutar por ela com todas
as armas disponíveis.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também. No canal do
além do se envolva. Ah.